harry potter and the deathly hallows
part 1 the video game that is released
back in the year 2010 and it was by and
large pretty much a universal
disappointment among harry potter fans
now if someone out there actually
enjoyed the game i don't want to insult
you that's totally fine if you liked it
but i think for the most part fans and
critics alike were not all that enthused
with the quality of deathly hallows part
1 and eventually part 2 as well you see
the developers at ea had a very
interesting decision to make because for
those who have read the harry potter
books or seen the harry potter movies
you know that book 7 represents a pretty
big shift in the overall tone but mainly
the setting with so much of the action
taking place outside of hogwarts it
makes sense that the video game had to
change somewhat unfortunately the way
they changed the game was in really all
the wrong reasons they went all in on
the action in fact a lot of people still
to this day refer to it as call of
potter basically implying that it
essentially turned into a call of duty
clone in the third person form with
harry potter and spells and while many
of the other games before it were kind
of a mixed bag it still seemed that
everyone learned all the wrong lessons
so how is it that a video game series
that started all the way back in 2001
with a movie tie-in game on the pc that
really wasn't bad for its time in harry
potter and the source for stone or floss
for stone depending on where you live in
fact if you look at the complete history
of harry potter video games they tell a
very interesting story there's been some
good there's been some bad and there's
been a lot of in between so what can
hogwarts legacy learn what can hogwarts
legacy take from these titles that will
actually make it end up being a better
game now some of this is going to be
good and some of this is going to be bad
like pointing back to these games and
saying no
don't do this and so i think one of the
first and most important things is a
lesson right there from harry potter and
the deathly hallows don't try and be
something you're not with the deathly
hallows video game they essentially took
what was an adventure title and made it
into a shooter title instead which i
don't care about the change in setting
you absolutely cannot do that the series
has always been about the adventure the
story the lore and so essentially taking
all of that and turning it into nothing
more than a shooter was definitely a bad
move now the good news here is we
already know that hogwarts legacy is not
doing this now what we don't know though
is what the balance is like we've seen
combat and i know that some people seem
excited about it some people aren't so
excited about it based on what we've
seen so far i personally think it looks
pretty good a lot of people have talked
about how the enemies don't really
appear to attack in more than groups of
just one person at a time but my hope
here is that the demo we saw was
basically on the lowest difficulty set
and we know there's going to be multiple
difficulties of course they could just
be showcasing things for the purposes of
that demo as well we don't know that
that's exactly how it's going to play
and we also frankly don't know how the
combat is going to feel that's really
the main thing right how does it flow as
you're actually playing the game and
interacting with all of these enemies
now on the more positive side some of
the most beloved harry potter games are
the first three so sorcerer's stone
chamber of secrets and prisoner of
azkaban now i've seen people kind of
disagree on whether they prefer the pc
or the console versions but regardless
of which one you like better it was
really that exploration and that sense
of discovery from those games that
people liked so much honestly i would
have enjoyed chamber of secrets on the
gamecube even more if it wasn't for all
the loading screens that interrupt you
almost every time you go into a new room
go to a new area so that's kind of
annoying hopefully we won't have to
worry about a lot of load screens with
hogwarts legacy so i really hope that
hogwarts legacy goes all in on that
sense of exploration now they're saying
the right things in the developer behind
the scenes that aired at the end of the
state of play they absolutely seemed
like they get it and that is one thing
that i really took from that state of
play more than anything else is that i
do feel like the developers and the
people working on this game truly get
what has made for a good harry potter
game in some cases of the previous games
and also what hasn't made for such a
great game they really seem to get that
hogwarts is sort of the central hub for
everything hogwarts they have to nail
that experience for it all to be
worthwhile right so embrace that lore of
hogwarts embrace the secret passages
embrace the four hogwarts common rooms
and the houses which again from what
we've seen so far it totally seems like
they are embracing these things and
specifically when it comes to the lore i
think there's a very interesting balance
here because when i was watching the
movies originally as a kid i was so
disappointed when they made any little
change and over time i started to
understand some of those changes and
still to this day there are some changes
that drive me crazy anytime i see the
movies on tv and this is just going to
always be the case with any sort of
beloved property they have to strike a
very careful balance here of embracing
the lore embracing some things that are
established in canon but also trying to
do some new things and i would never
advocate for completely breaking the
cannon that's just not in me i can't do
it but in some cases i am okay with them
kind of bending the canon just a little
bit if it makes for a better video game
experience and truth be told when it
comes to the old harry potter games i
know some of you may disagree with me on
this that's okay i don't ever think
there's really been a great harry potter
game there have been some good harry
potter games some average some mediocre
and then some just downright bad harry
potter games but i really don't think
we've truly had a great harry potter
game so that is why i think so many
people are excited for hogwarts psycho
season because it truly has a chance to
do something that we've never seen
before and make a hogwarts game that
actually lives up to the original series
now one thing i would argue that none of
the games have ever quite nailed is the
magic and spell casting system i'm not a
game developer so i can't say exactly
what will make for the perfect system i
have some ideas based on previous games
that i played but a lot of those games
in my mind also have some sort of melee
ability that goes with them as well but
with hogwarts legacy with harry potter
your wand is really kind of exclusively
the tool that you'll use both in battle
and for puzzle solving now they can
definitely get creative maybe with
transfiguring some objects and things
like that and when it comes to spells we
actually know about quite a few already
we can hear the character say all of
these right here i'll put them on the
screen for you now in the trailer we
hear these verbally called out so we
know these are all going to be in the
game so the system of categorizing and
being able to select and switch between
different spells on the fly is going to
play a huge role in how that gameplay
feels i still think they'll ultimately
go with some sort of spell wheel system
where we'll be able to pull up all of
them at once and then quickly switch on
the fly and then i would also expect
we'll be able to hotkey some of the
spells to specific buttons and one other
positive thing i think they could take
from some of those old harry potter
games is that there are many games that
can actually work many games are always
sort of a touchy subject with any video
game because obviously they call them
mini games for a reason it's kind of
just a distraction to the main thing
that you're doing but frankly i loved
tossing the garden gnomes in chamber
secrets i thought that was super fun and
even quidditch i thought they did a
decent job with in the console games and
we still don't know if quidditch is in
the game just yet and it really does
seem like the wizarding world already
has so many things that are just ready
to be minigames you've got gobstones
you've got exploding snap you've got
wizard chess we already know about
broomstick flying they've also talked
about potions and caring for magical
creatures so i think there could
definitely be some mini games that you
work in there as well but overall and
i'll just tell you guys this may be a
controversial thing for me to say i hope
it's not hope you don't get too upset
with me but if i'm going gonna be
completely honest with you i hope that
hogwarts legacy takes more inspiration
from more modern and recent games as
opposed to the old school harry potter
games look i totally get the nostalgia
there are a lot of things about those
games that i love but at the end of the
day i just keep coming back to the fact
that none of them ever truly captured
what i feel a harry potter game could
ultimately be and i think hogwarts
legacy has an excellent chance to do
just that okay one thing they can
absolutely take from the old games
though the music right how about the
music the music was so good especially
in the earlier harry potter video games
that is one area i think we can all
agree that the original games just did a
phenomenal job with and when it comes to
the lore we actually know quite a bit
already about how hogwarts legacy will
be handling the original canon you can
check out the video on the right side of
your screen now if you're curious about
that as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon